Me piden que factorice 25x cuadrada menos 30x más 9.
Lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta es que el lado de la "x" cuadrada no tenemos un 1, tenemos un 25
pero, podemos factorizar esto por agrupación, y antes de proseguir
lo primero que quiero que veas es que no tenemos un factor común,
25 y 30 tienen como factor común 5 pero, ya con 9 no, y
30 y 9 tienen como factor común el 3 pero el 25 no, entonces se me ocurre que tal vez y sólo tal vez,
esta expresión que nos piden factorizar se pueda ver como un binomio al cuadrado perfecto,
porque fíjate que 25x cuadrada tiene raíz cuadrada
exacta y 9 también tiene raíz cuadrada exacta.
Entonces vamos a ver qué pasaba con las expresiones que se veían de este estilo.
Cuando yo tenía algo de la forma
ax más "b" que multiplicaba ax más "b"  o ax más "b" al cuadrado
ax más "b" elevado al cuadrado pues esto era lo mismo que
multiplicar ax más "b" por ax más "b" entonces vamos a escribirlo así,
y vamos a realizar la multiplicación de un binomio por un binomio.
¿Y qué me va a quedar? ax por ax me va a quedar "a" cuadrada "x" cuadrada
entonces déjame escribirlo aquí, "a" cuadrada "x" cuadrada, y después tengo que sumarle
ax por "b" es lo mismo que abx
y después tengo "b" que multiplica a
ax y esto también es abx.
Entonces lo voy a poner aquí abx y por último tengo "b" que multiplica a "b" que es "b" cuadrada
y esto todavía lo podemos simplificar un poco.
Me va a quedar "a" cuadrada "x" cuadrada y después tengo abx más abx
es lo mismo que 2 veces abx
y a esto le sumamos "b" cuadrada y bueno, esta es la expresión equivalente
que nos queda al tener la expresión ax más "b"
elevada al cuadrado y bueno, si yo quisiera o si de pura casualidad
pensara que esto es un binomio al cuadrado perfecto entonces 25x cuadrada
tendría que ser "a" cuadrada "x" cuadrada, 2 veces abx tendrá que ser -30x
y "b" cuadrada tendrá que ser 9, o dicho de otra manera "a" cuadrada tendría que ser 25
y "b" cuadrada tendría que ser 9, "b" cuadrada tendría que ser 9.
Yo estoy suponiendo que tal vez se vea de esta manera,
no forzosamente tiene que ser un binomio cuadrado perfecto
pero bueno, la raíz cuadrada de 25 es más -5,
y la raíz cuadrada de 9 es más -3 y sería muy bueno revisar que aquí en medio estuviera dos veces ab
2 veces abx o 2 veces ab, es más podemos decir que 2 veces ab es igual a -30
2 veces ab es igual a -30 y vamos a ver qué
posibilidades tenemos con esto.
2 veces ab igual a -30 y si dividido ambos lados entre 2 me va a quedar que ab es lo mismo que
15, - 15 y entonces qué posibilidades tengo 5 por 3 me dan 15
pero fíjate que necesito que los signos coincidan también,
por lo tanto me puedo tomar el valor de 5 positivo,
y 3 negativo, déjame escribirlo aquí, puede ser que
"a" valga 5 y "b" valga -3 ó en su dado caso que sea al revés,
que "a" valga -5 y "b" valga 3 positivo.
Entonces lo voy a escribir aquí
"a" puede valer 5 positivo y en su dado caso "b" puede valer -3
porque fíjate que 5 por -3 me va a dar -15 hasta aquí vamos bien,
y mi otra posibilidad es que "a"
valga menos 5 y "b" valga 3 positivo menos 5 por más 3 me da
15 negativo, y aquí es cuando nos ponemos bastante contentos,
porque entonces sí, en efecto es un binomio al cuadrado perfecto.
¡Ojo! No forzosamente tenía que serlo pero, nos acabamos de dar cuenta
que sí cumple esta ecuación.
Entonces nos puede quedar 5x menos 3 elevado al cuadrado
5x menos 3 elevado al cuadrado, o en su dado caso podemos ver la otra opción.
La otra opciones es que "a"
valga -5 y "b" valga 3 positivo es decir, me quedaría algo como -5x más 3
-5x más 3 elevado al cuadrado
y bueno me gustaría saber si estas dos expresiones son lo mismo, porque yo tengo 2 resultados
y parece ser que esto es un poco ambiguo
pero si te das cuenta en el resultado derecho yo puedo factorizar un -1.
Fíjate bien si factorizas -1 me va a quedar la siguiente expresión
-1 que multiplica ¿A quién?
-5x entre -1 me da 5x positivo y 3 entre -1 me da -3 y todo esto elevado al cuadrado
y bueno si separamos los cuadrados me va a quedar -1 elevado al cuadrado por
5x -3 elevado al cuadrado pero, -1 al cuadrado es 1 entonces me quedaría de resultado
exactamente lo mismo que tengo a la izquierda 5x-3
elevado al cuadrado y entonces nos acabamos de dar cuenta
que esta es la solución de la factorización,
de la expresión que yo tenía aquí arriba.